So, all right. So we're back. Peak Mind podcast recorded in X spaces. Today, we have a guest, Morgan Farrell of Intuitive Underground. He's a remote viewing instructor with years of experience, I think at least 15, but he's going to clue us in on the exact details in a moment.
We studied under Ed Dames, the individual who brought remote viewing public, and we wanted to talk to him today about technical remote viewing, how he got involved in it, and his organization, Intuitive Underground, and we wanted to get into, we want to get into Intuitive Underground's most notable work, and basically how Morgan and I met and how we've worked together.
So, uh, I just wanted a quick note of housekeeping. Um, I, you know, when we started these, um, running these, uh, spaces, this podcast, I, I was trying to figure out how to organize it.
And so I started to come up with these sort of kind of elaborate plans and, uh, of how to organize the different, um, of how to organize the different, uh, podcasts and the structure of it.
Uh, in the past I've run spaces and I've tried to run like one subject, um, after another sort of connected the ties together.
But all I really did was put myself into a hole and I have, uh, I get a lot, like a pretty busy life and I get really tired.
And so the first couple of, um, spaces just weren't really what, what I was intending them to be.
And so what had occurred to me that the best way to do it was to bring Morgan in and start from that point and work forward.
And actually, before we get to the, the questions, Morgan, I wanted to quickly, um, ask you what, um, how do you, what mechanism do you use to randomize your, um, sessions?
Right.
So you have targets you, I know you're going to randomize the sessions, but how do you arrange it so that you don't remember which numbers are which target?
Like, do you use a randomizer or is there a, a computer programmer?
Oh, um, how, how do I, well, as, as a tasker or project manager, um, it doesn't really matter if I know what, what, uh, target reference numbers are associated with which target.
Um, so I do, I, I do all that manually.
See, I want to randomize the podcast because then I won't start thinking like, I won't start thinking in what way to, you know, organize it and, and get into the weeds of like making things too elaborate for, you know, for no real benefit or no real gain.
But, but it's beyond me, like Matt's great and you're always great, but you know, it's just my, my capabilities at this time really aren't there to create this sort of elaborate structure, you know?
So I just want to randomize the, the, um, the topics.
And I thought I'd ask you for suggestions, but I'm sure I can figure it out, like how to do it.
I put them in a shoe box or something.
Uh, Hey Matt, this is Morgan.
Morgan.
This is Matt.
Matt is my, uh, my younger brother, Morgan.
And, uh, Morgan is my, uh, my friend.
We've, uh, worked together, um, on Astro RV and RV related, uh, material.
Uh, yeah.
Hey Matt, how are you?
Nice to meet you, man.
Nice to meet you too, Morgan.
I'm good.
How are you?
Oh, I'm doing all right.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Just FYI.
I'll front load it by saying I'm, uh, I'm, uh, I'm, uh, I'm,
just at the tail end of a pretty nasty cough I'd picked up, uh, at the end of last week.
So I'll, I'll try and hold out as long as I can.
But, uh, every now and again, I'm going to have to scramble for the, uh, cough button.
See case in point.
Look, so every week I do a space or every time I record a podcast with Matt, I have an excuse
and elaborate set of, uh, rationalizations for why I'm not at the top of my game.
Well, today I, I was tired from dealing with the cats and I was tired from doctor's appointments
and I was sorry, like I have a whole list, right?
The truth is like, maybe I'm just not meant to be Joe Rogan.
Right.
But, uh, we just keep going on.
So it doesn't, we'll do the best and don't worry.
If you cough, you cough.
Right.
If people, um, if someone eventually listens to this and they are put off by the fact that
you coughed, then they're just going to have to, they're going to have to like aim a little
higher, I guess, with who they choose to listen to.
Yeah.
Well, then we'll be onto their listening experience.
Sounds good.
I, I don't think we should let, uh, perfect be the enemy of the good or whatever the saying
is.
So it all sounds good to me.
Um, what I'll, what I'll say up front is I am not super familiar with remote viewing
or technical remote viewing.
And, um, I think that might be valuable, um, depending on what direction you guys want to
go for the podcast or at least for this episode, because it kind of gives a different perspective,
maybe, especially for people that, um, aren't super familiar that might be listening and maybe
encountering remote viewing for the first time or, or one of the first times.
Um, so I may ask, um, you know, pretty, you know, junior level questions.
Um, you know, what does this mean and, and, and whatnot.
Um, if that's okay with y'all.
Um, there are five prepared questions that, that JT is, um, put together that I, that I'll
ask to kind of provide some structure.
But along the way, um, I may ask some, you know, uh, some questions about like, what does
something mean or where does that come from?
Um, if that's okay with y'all.
Oh, of course.
And Hey, there are no stupid questions.
Um, only stupid answers.
And since I'm the one answering that's on me.
Okay.
Sounds good.
Um, so should we get right to it then?
Or is there anything else?
All right.
So, uh, one of the first prepared questions is remote viewing emerged into the civilian world
in the 1990s.
Uh, I understand that you knew the founder of public remote viewing at dames, uh, Morgan,
how did he bring our remote viewing into the public and, uh, what was it like to know him?
Uh, okay.
That's a great place to start.
Um, so RV, um, um,
Um, the, the story is actually rather complicated and involved.
Um, parts of the RV program, uh, were actually never classified.
They were, uh, they were, uh, they were considered unclassified and so technically, um, access to
certain parts of, um, at least the research and development arm, um, the work that was going
on at, uh, Stanford through the seventies and eighties, much of that was actually unclassified.
Um, so there, there has been a certain level of information available throughout the program's
existence, uh, to the public.
Um, it, um, it, the classified part was primarily, um, the operations unit, uh, based out of Fort
Meade, Maryland.
Um, it really emerged into the public consciousness, uh, after full declassification of, of the
operational, uh, size by program in, I think it was, uh, August, 1995, and it kind of blew
up from there.
Um, Ed had actually started, uh, his, his private sector, uh, consulting and training company,
CyTech in 1989, and they had been operating, uh, primarily as a contractor, uh, for, uh, government
agencies, uh, until full declassification in the mid nineties, uh, at which point it, uh,
it became fully open to the public.
Um, now I was not of course involved, uh, as I was nine years old at that time.
Um, so my involvement came, uh, quite a bit later.
Okay.
So, um, it sounds like there was, um, unclassified work done at Stanford at a university.
So that's been kind of public knowledge for a while, but then there was some classified
operations that were declassified in the mid nineties.
And that's sort of when it became public.
Um, so when did you meet Ed?
Yeah, it's, uh, it became public yet in the, in the mid nineties.
And I mean, much of it, uh, on the operation side is still classified to this day.
Um, but the military's admitted involvement and, and use of this technology, um, it was fully
admitted in the nineties.
Yeah.
Um, so I found remote viewing in 2011.
Um, I had, uh, in, uh, at this point in a previous life, uh, I worked in, uh, union construction
and I had, uh, I had a workplace incident that basically ruined my back and, uh, hence my
ability to work in that, uh, field.
So at that time I was, uh, I was off work recovering and, you know, with very little else, uh, to do,
spend a lot of time surfing the internet and kind of rekindled my, uh, lost interest in,
um, the mysterious, um, you know, the nature of our reality and what it, what it means to
be a human being, um, you know, conspiracy stuff, UFOs, ghosts, all, all that sort of
thing.
And I actually don't remember exactly where I first came across the concept, but wherever,
wherever that was, it's probably a YouTube video or something.
And it caught my attention.
Um, the way that they were talking about, about remote viewing as a teachable, learnable
system for controlled psychic functioning.
Sounded, you know, on its surface, it almost sounds too good to be true, but the way that
these people were talking about it was, was very serious and these people sound, you know,
a very sound mind.
So enough that it caught my attention, I thought, well, this warrants further investigation.
So I investigated further on my own and pretty quickly I discovered, okay, um, there, there's
more than enough, uh, here that, yeah, this does appear to be legitimate.
And as an extension of that, well, if this is in fact a legitimate, uh, phenomenon, this
might be the best means to an end.
The end being, you know, I'm looking for answers to all these mysteries that I'm interested in.
Um, the problem with research, as, as I'm sure you guys and anyone listening, uh, recognizes
is that research is only as good as its source, as its author.
So you can read X number of books, you can read 40 books on a given subject, and you could
potentially come away with 40 valid sounding points of view.
So, so you're really actually no further ahead than you, than you were when you first started.
And in fact, you might actually have taken one step forward and two back because now you've,
you've thought of even more questions you didn't even know to ask in the first place.
And, you know, rabbit holes, we get other rabbit holes and it just becomes an virtually an infinite
looping system.
So that was, that was what really attracted me to remote viewing.
I thought, okay, if this is a real thing, these people all seem to claim that it, it can be
learned by virtually anyone.
Um, and at that time I had plenty of time and I had a bit of money to invest, um, at least
in the early stages, I thought, well, for, for very little, I can purchase a home study course
that was offered by ad, uh, at that time and I can see it for myself.
So that was exactly what I did.
And very quickly I discovered that.
Okay.
Not only is this real, it's a, it's a absolutely viable tool for the purposes that I've been
thinking about.
And I basically dove in head first, uh, after that point and never looked back.
Um, so it might be a good time to kind of define what remote viewing is and how it might be
distinguished from the technical remote viewing, uh, that I understand is, is sort of your focus.
So if you were asked to describe what remote viewing is to somebody who doesn't know much
about remote viewing or maybe nothing at all, um, well, how would you describe it and, and
how would you distinguish it from, from the, the technical remote viewing?
Okay.
Yeah.
Great question.
So I guess it's probably, uh, the right time to, to point out that the term remote viewing,
depending on the context can refer to, or does refer to both a, a protocol and a method,
realistically, various protocols and various methods.
So protocol, of course, refers to, um, the experimental setup, the arrangement, the logistics.
Method refers to the technique that the remote viewer actively uses to collect information psychically.
So a, and there are, of course, there are plenty of variants, as I mentioned on, on both.
So we'll try and keep it fairly straightforward.
Uh, so a standard, um, remote viewing protocol, the setup would look something like this.
You would have, uh, a minimum of two people involved, a project manager, tasker, and a remote
viewer.
So project manager essentially decides the target that is to be remote viewed that we want information
about now in a training scenario, the target is always going to be something that is readily
verifiable, right?
Um, obviously for feedback and learning training purposes.
So what we would do is we would either using a photo reference or a written set of instructions,
we would choose a specific target, uh, for example, the Paris or, uh, the Eiffel tower in Paris, France.
So I would take either a photo of the Eiffel tower, or I would write out the Eiffel tower, Paris, France.
And then I would assign that target, something we call a TRN target reference number, uh, TRN
is just an, we've settled on these, uh, standardized eight digits.
The number of digits is arbitrary.
The actual number itself is arbitrary.
It's effectively a file number.
So let's say we had, uh, the Eiffel tower in Paris, France target number.
Uh, and I'm just, I'm making this up off the top of my head.
Seven, five, five, three, eight, six, seven, nine.
The project manager tells the remote viewer, I have a target for you and passes along the
target reference number and that's it.
So no leading information.
The purpose of course, is to keep the viewer, what we call blind to the target.
Hence any data generated in the remote viewing session is.
Comes purely from their own mind.
So at this point, the viewer engages in their chosen method for collecting the information, generating
this data mentally, psychically produces a contemporaneous report, uh, or a record of that session,
uh, which involves recording on paper, um, a series of written descriptors, uh, and sketches.
Now these descriptors and sketches, um, are worked through in a strictly prescribed order, um, using
the technical remote viewing method.
And I'll come back to that in a second, after the session transcript, uh, the session is done.
The viewer formally ends their session and submits it, uh, to the project manager or in a training
scenario, they would be given, um, their target.
They would be unblinded, uh, immediately after, uh, for the purpose of review and grading and,
uh, beginning the, the feedback process.
So that's a basic overview of, of, uh, what, uh, an RV training target looks like.
I'm, I'm sure you can extrapolate from there how that might work in an operational scenario,
but it's basically the same.
It's a little more involved because the viewer may be, uh, asked to revisit something they've
identified in their session and run another session against just, just one specific component,
just to gather more, uh, specifics or detail.
And at the end of that, we assemble the work together and in an operational scenario, we
decide, well, what does this mean in context of the designated target?
So that's basically what protocol looks like.
Now, when it comes to method, there are, uh, there's a pretty wide spread of, of actual remote
viewing methods, um, in terms of how they're executed and what they look like.
Um, the original remote viewing, uh, studies were done using natural psychics who, of course,
at this point in time, there is no defined structured RV methods.
So they're basically just free form using their own psychic abilities and any method or pseudo
method that, that they have come up with.
Um, shortly after that, they started to bring in, uh, military and civilian control subjects.
And they discovered fairly quickly that every control subject they brought in, um, you know,
apparent non psychics actually were capable of producing similar results when they were shown
how, when they were kind of walked through the, the process, um, the goal of course, uh, being
for military intelligence purposes was eventually to come up with a teachable systems, uh, uh, a
method that could be taught to non psychics, uh, in this case, soldiers, um, for use against
uh, well, just about anything you could think of in terms of, uh, military intelligence, uh, collection.
So throughout, uh, the mid seventies through the early eighties, um, a couple of the scientists
involved at Stanford, um, primarily how put off, uh, and working again, primarily with, uh,
natural psychic or sensitive, uh, man named Ingo Swann, effectively reverse engineered Ingo's
natural psychic processes into a teachable, uh, set of steps, a structured, uh, what we call
stages, a series of steps that mimicked the process that they had, I guess, as I say, reverse
engineered what Ingo was doing in his own mind.
Um, the method I use, tactical remote viewing is kind of a next gen variant of the original
structured method.
Uh, the original structured method was called CRV coordinate remote viewing and later, uh,
renamed as controlled remote viewing because that was its ultimate, uh, that was really the
key to it was that it provided control over psychic functioning that, uh, many natural psychics
actually lack, um, control in terms of what you're doing on a moment by moment basis, but also
control in terms of teaching them when to, to determine when they are, uh, on target and
off, uh, basically a method of, uh, filtering the noise, uh, and improving the hypothetical signal
to noise ratio, uh, technical remote viewing was developed, um, in, in the, uh, in the private
sector, as I'd mentioned earlier, um, my mentor, uh, at dames, he started a company called sci-tech
in 1989.
And when it, when sci-tech services became open to the public, um, as you might, you know,
as you might guess, naturally that kind of opened up the, uh, the scope, uh, of the, the sort
of projects that remote viewing was applied towards.
And that process really started to, to highlight certain pitfalls, uh, that they tended to encounter
using the original method.
And so through years of refinement, um, they developed a, a modified system of the original
CRV method, uh, that Ed called technical remote viewing.
And without getting too far into the weeds on it, it's probably, it's probably easiest to
think of it as a, um, even more rigidly structured, um, but streamlined and efficient, uh, system.
That's probably, it's probably the easiest way to describe it.
And the technical remote viewing method is really probably easiest thought of as a series of rapid
fire questions and spontaneous answers.
We would call them prompt and response.
And it's divided into a series of steps, or as we call them stages, which alternate back and forth
between sketching and describing using, uh, well, sketches and, uh, word descriptors.
So stage one, we connect to the target.
There's a, I won't get too into it here, but there's a fairly simple procedure that effectively
comes down to it's a, it's a, a quick sketch stage two.
We begin by prompting for low level sensory and dimensional data about the target site, uh, textures,
colors, smells, tastes, temperatures, sounds, uh, dimensions, motions, densities, and that sort of
thing, um, fairly basic, fairly low level.
But the real secret here, the key to it all is just working your way into a sort of a metronomic
pace and kind of just falling into that groove and letting it flow.
Um, you could almost make a comparison to, to music, uh, at this point.
Uh, as I said, it's a, it's a prescribed series of prompts and responses.
So you'd prompt textures and you just record the immediate, spontaneous, uh, intuitive response
that comes to your mind.
Um, the information can come in depending on, on the individual.
It can come in as, uh, just, uh, kind of an abstract concept, a word idea.
Um, sometimes you can actually, you know, reach out with your hand and kind of mimic like you're
rubbing something at the site and you may encounter a subtle, actual sensation.
Of course, it's not a physical sensation.
It's more like you're triggering the memory of a sensation, but, uh, effectively the entire
process is this rapid fire Q and a prompt and response sketching, describing, sketching and
describing through higher and higher level stages.
So with each higher stage, um, we refine what we're looking at further and you can think
of it in terms of our psychic aperture is opening and the, so the wider it gets, the more, the
higher level of specificity and detail we're going to come into.
So by the time we get to stage four, we're really no longer concerned with basic kind of low
level sensory ideas.
And this is where we start getting into specifics, uh, tangibles, intangibles, uh, et cetera.
And at the end of this process, we gather up, uh, our stack of sheets, review it, and, uh,
essentially assemble our data onto one page that we call a site template, which is effectively,
um, basically a diagrammatic representation of the target with some line sketches and written
descriptors.
So from there, you review your site template and you would, uh, summarize, write a written
summary of what you perceived in session and then submit to the project manager.
And if they have their answer, then they'll call it projects done.
And there you go.
Um, as I mentioned, you know, maybe we need more specifics or more detail on one, uh, aspect
of the target.
Um, the viewer can be, can be sent back in to look at that specifically, but, uh, yeah, that's,
that's pretty much, it's pretty much what it looks like.
I mean, what I would add, although I'm not, again, you're the expert, I'm not an expert,
uh, in this subject, in this particular subject, expert in many subjects, not, not, um, the
details of technical remote viewing, unfortunately, although I, you know, I'm learning more every
day.
Um, and I have followed it for quite some time, but mostly like descriptions of session material
online.
Right.
So, um, it seems semantics is a big, um, is something that, uh, differentiates technical
remote viewing from regular remote viewing.
It seems like there's a, an emphasis on the semantics of the task, how it's structured,
um, the, um, sort of reducing it as much as possible to the bare, uh, essentials and the
use of certain words and phrases specifically in order to, um, in order to target certain information
as opposed to what I've seen with other branches of remote viewing, which is their tasks tend to
be something between like a story and a spell, you know, it's like sort of winding and, you
know, the, the viewer will go there and he'll stand there and I'll look at the book and, you
know, and then he'll see this page and he'll look at what's the third paragraph on the page
and then he'll go someplace else.
He uses a lot of, um, a lot of metaphorical assumptions.
Oftentimes when I, when I will see or read about, um, other branches of RV and how they
task targets, but I don't think that's the case at all with technical RV.
So would you say that is also one of the things that differentiates, uh, TRV from other branches
of RV?
Oh, absolutely.
I would.
Um, and you know, I, I used the word streamlined and refined, um, earlier.
Um, those are, those are two of my go-to words to describe the difference between TRV and pretty
much, pretty much any other system.
And it's probably actually important to maybe expand on, on the idea that, so I've been talking
about TRV as, as a strict method, but in fact, TRV is, uh, a broader system, uh, in fact, and
that does go, um, into the project management end of things.
We do things a little bit differently, um, than other schools of RV do as JT just kind of
indicated, uh, one of them is in how we do our, our targeting and, uh, I had always referred
to the, the way that we do our targeting as working with the syntax and grammar of the
unconscious mind and it, in my opinion, it's a little bit more involved, a little bit more
thought and strategy goes into designing a target for a TRV session.
Um, because generally when we're trying to solve a problem, we're, we're looking for something
very specific and if you're not careful, if you leave your query, uh, to open, the viewer
is going to, they're going to respond to your targeting strategy.
So the broader, the scope in a given target, well, the broader, the viewers results are likely
to be.
So it's a bit of a balancing act because there are cases where you want to leave, uh,
a certain amount of open-endedness for, you know, perhaps, uh, something that you didn't
consider, uh, as a, as a targeter, um, but you also want to narrow it enough that the viewer
is unlikely to flounder around.
And as you say, kind of jump between things and ideas, we're usually looking for something,
uh, relatively discreet.
So yeah, the, the entire system is, is a little different.
Um, not significantly, uh, well, I guess that's a matter of opinion.
Um, and in some ways it is significantly different than other schools, but in other ways it's really
not, um, you know, uh, when I talk to remote viewers from, from other schools, we all speak, uh, slight
variants of the same umbrella dialect.
If you want to look at it in those terms, but, uh, there are, there are certainly, uh, distinct
differences between schools and their, their approaches, uh, from everything from method to targeting
strategies.
Um, but beyond just targeting strategies, uh, it's also, well, it's a, it's really, it's a
mentality and, you know, how do you, how do you think about these kinds of things?
And that was, that was one area where Ed, um, uh, in my opinion was relatively unique, uh,
among the others in that unit.
He had a very, very practical and strategic mindset towards the application of remote viewing.
And that's what we largely owe, um, the refined system that we use today to, um, is Ed's strategic,
uh, an applications oriented mindset.
Yeah.
So one thing you and I have talked about, and I believe I've talked about it with Matt, but
it's too much to get into today because we're just starting with the basics.
Um, and this is entirely possibly projection on my part, right?
Like this is entirely speculative.
Um, well, not this.
So the first part is like the syntax and grammar of the collective unconsciousness, unconscious,
excuse me, is incredibly important.
Like that is, I think the, the, the most important thing, um, about TRV and, and Ed Dames thought,
uh, because it's just a completely different way of approaching it.
And as I pointed out, um, metaphors and the assumptions and the narrative that other, uh,
branches of RV and, and other project managers seem to use really are reminiscent of something
more new agey or occult.
And I'm not saying it is, I'm saying the mentality, I think that informs it is such that it's almost
like they're, they just, they don't, I don't think they believe they're accessing the collective
unconscious.
I believe they have other explanations for how RV works.
And those explanations are inefficient and inaccurate in my opinion.
Again, this is speculative.
I have, um, you know, we often talk about technology in, in the military and technology that the government
has being decades ahead of the public.
I don't think it's a controversial statement.
I think it's something we pretty much all accept at this point.
Um, I know that there has, you know, I myself have heard people who would have a reason to
know, say that AI was developed decades before it was developed publicly, right?
You know, at the nineties before the nineties, but definitely was, was working.
You know, there was, there, there were working AI, um, models in the 1990s.
This, this is what I understand.
Now I, I can't say for certain, like, I don't know anything about the classified details of
events grid.
This is just projection, but on my part or speculation, but the way he approached remote
viewing.
Um, when I, when Matt, my brother right here, uh, when Matt explained to me how AI works,
I immediately had an epiphany and I was like, I think Ed understood how AI worked.
I don't know if he, if he had any firsthand knowledge of it, if he had RV knowledge of
it, if, if there was overlap between the programs, which I think is most likely, I think that's,
that's not a big leap, but who knows.
Um, but it seems to me that the way he thought about remote viewing was very similar to the
way a context engineer would think about utilizing, um, AI in order to, um, you know, in order to,
uh, get the best possible result from, from that unit, including things like streamlining and using
the right syntax and grammar, right.
Which from what Matt has explained to me, right.
AI has a context window and you have to kind of limit the amount of context that you, um, you use
so that you don't get hallucination or other issues.
Right.
And in that same way, I think that TRV is designed, as you said, to streamline it and get specific
answers as opposed to.
You know, bringing back information that is extraneous to the project.
I mean, does that sound plausible?
Yeah, it sounds plausible, uh, on several levels.
Um, just from a practical standpoint, um, I mean, the, the analogy you give here is accurate.
Um, that was a really good way of putting it.
Um, now as far as if, and we can probably safely assume that sure, um, you know, the, the upper
echelons of military intelligence, of course they would have had access to, um, the kinds
of AI or LLM, uh, systems that we have today and their, their precursors, they would have had
access to those sorts of things.
Um, you know, we'll say the number that's always floated around, we'll say nominally 30
years, uh, ahead of what's publicly available.
I mean, that's just, that's basically established fact, um, uh, at this point and for, for obvious
reasons, right.
You know, they have to, uh, emerging, uh, technologies need to be understood, um, for any possible way
they could be exploited as, as, as a weapon system before they can be unleashed to the public
for, uh, national and international security reasons.
Sure.
Makes perfect sense.
Now, um, kind of drawing a line from that.
Yes.
Ed was involved in very high level military intelligence, uh, stuff, uh, in varying capacities,
uh, throughout, especially the later part of his career.
So do I have firsthand knowledge that he had access to, uh, the systems or prototypes of
these systems, um, you know, in the eighties and the nineties, uh, firsthand knowledge?
No.
Um, can I infer the possibility of that?
Yes.
The likelihood even may be, um, and you know, there actually, there are a couple of people
that, uh, I could talk to who might have more information on that.
So if I can get more information on that, uh, I'll certainly let you know, but, uh, I, I
currently don't have any, uh, firsthand knowledge, um, on that.
However, it does track, uh, logically.
So what I think is, uh, ironic about the TRB, and I think we'll get into this in the next
question, maybe, um, you know, is that, uh, uh, you guys, um, like Ed got out there and
he was really ahead of the game.
He sort of like, it was a one man, you know, production for years, like RV.
And then the other RV, um, uh, other individuals from the program came out and they began their
public careers.
As time went on, things happened that caused TRB to sort of fall out of favor.
I don't think it's a controversial statement.
I think it's just, you know, an observation and, um, the, the other methods of RV that sort
of gained public favor, um, are ones that aren't as well adapted in my opinion for individuals
who understand this emerging technology today.
So I think that the opportunity for TRB, and we're not necessarily talking about the opportunity
for TRB today, but, you know, just as a personal note, I think that the opportunity is that people
who are familiar with the emerging technology, right?
Given the, um, given a survey of the different types of, uh, and methods of RV around today,
um, will naturally, I think, understand and, um, gravitate towards the TRB method because
it's, you know, it's, it's, it's, it easily fits in metaphors.
They will understand, and I think they'll be able to grasp why it's more efficient, like
why it's a better method, in my opinion.
Um, Hey Matt, uh, do you want to move on to the next question or do you have any follow-up
questions?
So, I mean, I, I think that I could probably spend a long time asking pretty basic questions
about remote viewing.
Um, but I don't want to bog down the podcast before we get to some of the other topics,
which maybe we want to get to, but I guess what I would like to do is maybe, um, with the
interest of, of people that don't know about remote viewing as, as much, um, try to relate
it to something in like pop culture.
And I'm just wondering, is it, would it be, you know, obviously this is a, it's a, it's
a drama, but, um, could you, you know, have you seen stranger things, either of you, both
of you?
I've seen the first season and the second season, just not the third.
Yeah.
I, uh, I, I've not watched it.
I mean, of course familiar cause it's, it's quite popular.
Um, but no, I haven't, I haven't watched it.
Okay.
Well in, in the show, there's a character who is like psychic and it's a part of a government,
uh, program, right.
That, that seems to me to be like very closely related to remote viewing.
And the idea was that she had this psychic ability, this character and, um, the, the, the
person who was running the program would give her a target and she would enter this, you
know, tank where, you know, she's floating and there's no sensation and just in her mind,
she's just thinking about this target.
And, and then she would be kind of like transported to another realm where she might be able to see
like what that person was doing, who they were talking with things like this.
And I, I imagine it's not the same because it's a TV show, but would it be accurate to
say that in remote viewing, the tasker gives like could give like a person and then they
would be able to like sense, like, do they see visions?
Do they, do they just, or do they just know the information?
Like, like what, what is it like for somebody who's never really experienced what that may
be?
Like, do you like, do you see things?
Do you feel things?
Do you, or, or do you just know things or is it different for everybody?
Oh, actually, that's a really great question.
So, um, yeah, from, from what you just described and from my prior understanding, uh, a lot of
that stuff from that show is certainly inspired by the military program.
Um, naturally it'll be, uh, dramatized fairly heavily for, for television and, you know, to
make, uh, to make something entertaining, but, um, the, the general process you're talking
about, it's, it's not too far off now, as far as from a, an experiential standpoint, um,
the, the experience of running a session depends on a couple of things.
One, what method you're using.
So, uh, TRV method is, is by design, actually, um, the viewer kind of keeps the target and
the target information somewhat at arm's length.
So it's actually not terribly experiential in terms of, uh, well, you could, uh, make a comparison
to something like an out of body experience, right?
So the way, okay, maybe the simplest way that I could explain this is through, uh, a key
concept, um, in remote viewing is called bi-location.
A bi-location refers to the act of splitting one's attention between their immediate surroundings
and a remote target site or, uh, pattern of information, um, because it's not necessarily
always going to be a physical person, place thing or event, um, that we're gathering information
about.
Sometimes it's a more abstract thing, like a thought or an idea.
So, uh, at the end of the day, remote viewing is an attention management skill.
Now, how you go about that, as I mentioned earlier, there are, there are various methods.
Um, one method is called extended remote viewing or ERV, and that is much closer, although not
the same, but it's much closer, uh, to something like an out of body experience where it is fairly
experiential.
You, you do get, uh, strong visuals.
Um, but the visuals tend to be, uh, they aren't clear.
They're not, um, you know, full high fidelity, uh, vision, you know, that like you see through
your eyes in your immediate surroundings, it's kind of mind's eye vision.
It's probably the most practical way I can explain it would be, it's, it's kind of like a beaver
dream.
Uh, it's, it's a little, it's hard to focus.
Uh, things are a little blurry.
Um, it tends to be rather monochromatic, um, as opposed to full color visuals.
Um, and somewhat fleeting, um, it's very, it's very difficult to focus for an extended period
of time on one, uh, scenario or action or activity.
Um, but yeah, using ERV method, um, that sounds a lot closer to the, uh, experience that you
describe as depicted in, uh, stranger things.
Um, now I am trained in ERV.
Um, I fairly seldom use it, um, just again, for practical purposes.
Um, I just, I find TRV method to be far more streamlined and efficient in terms of, because,
uh, okay, the, on the, I used the term by location earlier, earlier in reference to the act of
splitting one's attention between two places, uh, technical remote viewing, the ideal state
of by location is about 50 50 half of your attention on your immediate surroundings.
And in, uh, in, uh, recording your session transcript in real time, you know, writing down your perceptions,
sketching your perceptions.
The other part of your mind is a quote unquote, it's out there gathering the information, relaying
it back to the part of your attention.
Um, doing the recording now methods like ERV, uh, they trend far closer to the 100%, uh, attention
at the target site, uh, end of that gradient or spectrum.
Um, now in, in practical terms, very seldom, very seldom do you actually reach 100%.
It's probably more in the 70 to 75% range.
Uh, hence the, uh, kind of semi distorted visuals, the, the monochromatic nature of the visuals.
Um, however, even at that point, it's not all visual information.
There is some, uh, what you might think of as, uh, Claire sentience or Claire cognizance,
which is basically just, uh, spontaneous knowing.
So you might see, uh, an activity taking place and you'll, you'll know from what you're seeing
what's going on, but you will also get another layer of information about what's happening just
by, you know, Claire sentience, Claire cognizance.
You'll just, you'll know, um, TRV is
a lot closer to Claire sentience or Claire cognizance in that typically you will just,
you'll just get ideas and, and concepts about what's going on.
Um, and they may not even be in any particular order.
You kind of have to reassemble it after, as I kind of talked about earlier.
Um, now the reason, or at least one of the main reasons, um, I prefer TRV is that the more
experiential a, a remote viewing session becomes, the more likely you are to kind of fall off track
and you, you kind of become absorbed in the experience and you will tend to forget in the
moment what you're actually supposed to be doing.
Um, and that is, that's a notorious problem for, um, well, something like out of body travel,
which tends towards about, uh, you know, 100% of your attention away from your body.
And what they find is that fairly quickly, um, at least if you're not very, very careful and
very diligent about it, um, the experience can turn subjective.
So realistically our job in using remote viewing as, as a problem solving tool, whether it's
for military intelligence purposes or for, for anything else, um, what we're looking to do
obviously is gather, um, objective information.
Um, now the more experiential your session becomes by nature, the more subjective the experience
becomes and things can fall apart rather quickly.
Does that, uh, does that kind of make sense?
The idea of by location and attention management.
It makes sense to me, um, it would make sense to me that if the more vivid or experiential,
like you're saying, um, the information is the less of your attention would be with your
body, which is just as important because if you don't remember afterwards and you haven't
recorded it in some way, the data that you're getting is only as good as, is if you can
share it and remember it in the future.
So I can understand, um, why that would be problematic.
Um, so thank you.
And I think I probably would have a lot more questions, but I don't, I think probably a little
bit at a time is, is best.
So I'm going to move on to the next for a second.
Of course.
No, yeah, please.
Uh, just, uh, ad living or, uh, adding to, um, well, just to answer your question, like specific
to Stranger Things, um, there is a storyline, there is a narrative or, um, who knows if it's
true or not, a set of rumors, uh, uh, amongst people who involved in RV related to the Montauk
project and the role the Montauk project played in RV.
Um, in fact, involving a computer and a chair and very stranger things ask.
I don't think it involved, although, you know, the, the legends always grow.
Right.
But I don't think that particular aspect of the Montauk program is alleged to involve like
time travel or interdimensional travel or any of those things that often get associated with
that program.
But that the Montauk program itself, uh, allegedly is what inspired the show Stranger Things.
So there is a connection there and maybe we can do a future podcast on that.
I was going to say possibly what we could do now is if, if I think Morgan can, I mean, I'm
not talking for you, Morgan, but I think you'd be willing at some point to come back hopefully
next week, but if not, you know, um, soon after and do a part two where we can get into
intuitive underground.
I think that for time's sake, we're going to have about 20 minutes.
So, um, probably talking about the kill shot and the predictions made, you know, by many
viewers and technical remote viewing, and then any questions, follow up questions that Matt
has probably the best way to wrap it up for today.
If that's all right with you.
Oh, Hey, by all means.
Um, yeah.
And let me just, uh, you just reminded me.
So, um, a former student of mine and current friend and colleague, uh, Theodore, um, if
you're, if you're interested in MaTalk stuff, uh, maybe he's someone you might want to talk
to.
That's, that's kind of his, uh, his favorite, uh, conspiracy.
So yeah, he, he might have a lot more to say on that specifically, uh, than I would,
but, uh, yeah, but yeah, we can head in, uh, whatever direction you like.
I'm, uh, no, I, I will, I'll, I'll write that down.
I'll add it to my list and I'm going to randomize it in some way, but I'll remember
T door and, and hopefully you can make a connection.
We'll, we'll, um, we'll have them on and talk about it at some point.
Um, go ahead, Matt.
I, again, I apologize for interjecting.
Oh, no, that's great.
Thank you.
All right.
So, um, moving in the direction of kill shot, uh, I've heard that Ed Dames and TRV are well
known for a certain set of targets, uh, maybe related to a solar event and, and that there's
a lot of controversy around that.
So could you elaborate on that?
Uh, yeah, sure.
So, and, and again, um, this, this stuff started long before my involvement.
Um, but the long story short is, uh, at some point in, in the late eighties, Ed and, and
the guys, oh, and I should mention too, um, virtually not all of them, but most of the military
remote viewers, um, that you later saw out in the public, they actually worked for Ed at
Scitech, uh, in its early days.
And that's really the, that's how all that started.
Um, so in the late eighties, um, the remote viewers started to become aware of an apparent
large scale disruption, uh, to society.
If not civilization, um, somewhere over the time horizon now further work, um, kind of refined
it down to an apparent primary cause that cause being a earth facing, uh, powerful X-class
solar flare and historically, um, there, there's precedent for such an event.
Uh, we need look no further than, uh, what we call the 1859 Carrington event where a, uh,
uh, uh, forgive me if I'm a little off on my details, but I believe he's a British astronomer
named Carrington who's observing the sun and noticed, um, significant, uh, earth directed,
uh, flares or CME coronal mass ejections.
So what happens there is, um, in the CME and now I'm, of course, I'm not a, I'm no astrophysicist,
but the sun effectively spews out particles and rays which reach the earth, um, at different
speeds.
So, uh, this interaction between, uh, solar material and earth's magnetic atmosphere is
what is responsible, uh, for the visual aurora effects that we see and we've been seeing them
uh, increasingly in recent years and at much farther south, uh, latitudes than, um, we, we tend
to, um, and so what they identified was that at some point we are basically, we, we absorb
a direct hit from a very powerful CME from the sun.
Now, what, uh, what happens in such a scenario.
And as I said before, we, we have encountered such a scenario, um, probably many times throughout
history.
However, it really only registers in, uh, anything close to the modern era in, in that 1859 Carrington
event where what happened was at the time, of course, we had by today's standards, very primitive,
uh, electrical and electronic, uh, systems and infrastructure, uh, mostly, uh, telegraph
stations and telegraph lines.
And what happened was this, uh, interference from the sun, the electromagnetic interference
actually overloaded the telegraph systems to the point where it was blowing out components.
Uh, I believe in some cases it was actually lighting, uh, the, some of the paper in the telegraph
machines on fire.
Um, so it was almost like a, a, a massive, uh, electrical feedback or a short circuit really,
um, just a massive, uh, electrical power overload blowing out the systems.
Now, uh, in 1859, a hit like that was pretty rough, but relatively innocuous in, in terms
of its effect on most people's daily lives.
Uh, if something like that were to happen today, we would be in very, very bad shape because
our, our electrical grid is not even close to hardened, uh, against the effects of, of such
an event.
Uh, what we would see if we were hit with, uh, an equivalent or more, or probably to some
degree, even a weaker, uh, hit than we took in the 1800s, we would see, uh, everything from
power lines to main transformers, uh, completely blown out.
We would be without, uh, wide scale, uh, access to electrical power for a very, very long period
of time.
Um, now these aren't current numbers, but as of probably, I would say maybe 10 years ago,
um, for each, uh, main, uh, junction transformer, like the, the big transformer boxes you'll see
at the corner of, of highways, there is a two year wait, uh, on, on these, uh, components
to be manufactured.
Now there is a steady, uh, of course, maintenance and replacement scheme in place.
So generally, you know, we know easily two or more years ahead of time when a transformer
needs to be replaced.
So that two year wait, not such a problem.
Now, if we had a whole bunch of these things blow out simultaneously, well, you can do the
math on that.
So Ed used to appear a lot on coast to coast AM, uh, beginning in the 1990s.
Um, and that's when I first started to, to listen to him, uh, on that, on the show, they
referred to him as Dr. Doom, which is actually kind of interesting from the standpoint of emerging
archetypes in the collective unconscious.
When you think about, um, you know, anyhow, you know, now with the Marvel and so, um, they
used to refer to him as Dr. Doom and he would, you know, they would do like a lost person,
uh, stuff they would talk about.
Um, but you know, his, it seemed like his real, like he, he strongly believed in the validity
of the kill shot data and he really wanted to prepare people, but they didn't really have
a sense of when it was going to happen.
Cause that's not really what RV does well, at least at that time, it didn't do it very
well.
And so he, he was talking about the kill shots in the late nineties, I believe.
Right.
And, um, in anticipating that it would happen, you know, over the horizon, but I think that
the mistake we can all acknowledge that Ed made for those out there who know who Ed
Dames is, is that he, and this is, look, this is not a criticism of him because this is all
of us, right?
Every one of us who 30 years ago, 40 years ago, whatever it was, became aware of the possibility
either through intuition or through new age, you know, the new age book section or coast
to coast AM of some sort of large civilizational discontinuity event.
Right.
We all believed it was imminent or far more imminent than it seems to have been.
Like I often tell people when the topic comes up, the end of the world is taking forever.
And I don't mean that like, you know, I don't mean that like, cause I, you know, I've said
that it hasn't happened yet.
I'm saying that, you know, we all kind of got on this train in the nineties and it just
never materialized.
And it, the, the fact that Ed found it was such an important topic to promote and continue
to promote it because he wanted people to get ready, uh, ended up bouncing back on technical
remote viewing and the technical remote viewing community.
Because he was making videos, uh, about how to prepare and, um, technical remote viewers
have a prompt, um, that they can use to, um, help individuals find the best possible place
for them to be during this event.
And so people were, um, they were hiring viewers to look for the best place for, you know, where
they themselves could be during the event.
And so enemies of remote viewing enemies of the idea of remote viewing, um, skeptics and,
uh, you know, probably people who wanted to keep, uh, remote viewing, um, accessible only
to certain groups of people.
Uh, they, uh, they, uh, they basically called it a grift, right?
They basically portrayed it as a giant money, uh, grabbing grift.
And, you know, Ed remained like he, he kept the faith until the end.
Um, even in the face of adversity and setbacks, I think it's important to note how many remote
viewers have seen this information in one form or another.
Whether it's, uh, just the solar flare or a magnetic pole shift related to the solar flare
and the civilizational discontinuity event.
I mean, you would say that's a fairly common thing for people who look at it to see.
Oh, a hundred.
I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't have a topic of the question.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
And, and so Ed, even when they broke down a series of events preceding this event, right?
So what's interesting is, um, some of the events preceding this event, uh, may have taken
place, right?
So for instance, uh, Ed did session work that many of us believe predicted the MRNA vaccinations,
right?
Now it's a very loaded topic.
Um, and, you know, God knows just mentioning it can get your, your, um, uh, can, can marginalize,
uh, your space or your posts, uh, because the algorithms will respond.
So, um, anyone can find what Ed had to say about the MRNA vaccinations in the late nineties,
early 2000, early aughts, um, by looking for that information from coast to coast AM and
they can still find that information.
Um, and I think that he was right.
I think he was correct.
So, um, there were other, there were in other, like an, there was another series of events
involving possibly the use of a nuclear weapon in the Korean peninsula involving a space shuttle
having to return to earth because of solar activity.
And something interesting is when the space shuttle program was retired, that was another
accusation that was leveled against technical remote viewers and Ed Dames and his company.
But it turns out that the, um, space shuttles themselves were continued in the form of a
drone used by the military.
So there are still space shuttles up in space, even though the space shuttle program was retired.
Um, and you know, one thing I think I've recently talked to.
Morgan about on X, um, they've started to find bird flu and cows.
And one of the, uh, if I remember correctly, one of the signs was, um, a, a large culling
of cattle herds, uh, were a series of events that would occur prior to this, um, scenario,
the kill shot scenario.
Uh, however, the biggest right associated event with the, um, the kill shot scenario, this,
this solar chrono mass ejection was the onset of world war three, like conditions where soldiers
would be out in the field.
Um, the world would be preparing for, or in the early stages of a large global conflict.
And then what would actually end that conflict was the, the kill shot that was the chrono mass
ejection in the sky.
Does this all sound, am I, am I recollecting correctly in, in, to, to your recollection?
Yeah, it's, it's all, it's all basically correct.
So we, you know, for the last 20 years, right?
25 years when Ed was talking about this, Ed has passed away, by the way, passed away early
this year, rest in peace.
Um, the world lost a legend and a, and a very, um, and a man who, who was very concerned about
the, of human, very concerned for humanity and human beings and other people.
Um, and, and it would, it would seem like that's a common thing, but it's not a common thing
at this point in time, at least.
So, uh, it's a, it's a huge loss that, that he passed away.
Um, yeah, so we have never been right.
We've had, um, we've had the Iraq war since he began talking, you know, we've had, um, like
minor conflicts, but we have never been, uh, since the beginning of these predictions, right?
We've never been in a situation where we're facing a potential global conflict and we are
already in the early stages of a, of a global conflict.
It's not potential anymore.
And people like to say, if, you know, world war three arrives, if, if the war expands, I
mean, there's, um, there's like an imaginary line in each person's mind, which would define
like a world war.
So, you know, we're not there in people's minds yet, but we're already involved in a
global conflict that's being fought in, in, uh, in Europe.
It's being fought in the middle East and it's being fought in Africa, which is something
that a lot of people are not aware of.
So what I'm saying is the, the general conditions for the fulfillment of what the remote viewers
have seen have never existed prior to this moment.
So people who criticize, um, criticize, criticize TRV and the TRV community for promoting this
information, uh, and look at it as sort of like a failed prediction or a series of failed
predictions, they're wrong, uh, because we've never been in the, we've never had the, the
basic, um, like series of events that would be necessary for it to take place.
Is there, is there anything that you, you can sort of add to that?
Um, I know I'm, I know I'm sort of being general, that's sort of a general topic.
Yeah, it's, there's, there's a lot there.
There's a whole lot there.
It's a, it's a huge umbrella subject with many, many sub topics, but no, I, um, as a general
overview that, that was, uh, quite accurate.
Um, and I believe, uh, your commentary is, is also correct.
Um, I can, I'm not going to say a whole lot right now, but we, we do have some, uh, some
work we're going to be putting out in the near to midterm future, uh, relevant to all of
this, um, in fact, just last night, I had a, uh, very extended conversation with, uh, probably
Ed's longest serving, uh, MIA.
That was his private company, Matrix Intelligence Agency, uh, team members.
And, uh, among many other things, we, uh, we discussed this topic.
Uh, in some detail.
So there's going to be, uh, there's going to be more on that coming out in the, in the
near to midterm future.
And, uh, I'll be, I'll be sure to let you know.
Um, okay.
Yeah.
Thanks.
So there was, um, a concept and I just want to bounce this off you.
Um, there was a concept.
There were many like speculation in the paranormal, all, all, um, of the different varieties or
branches of, of the paranormal really peaked in the 1990s.
And we've actually lost a lot of information, um, things that weren't copied to the internet
or were on the internet and then sort of faded away as people got older and passed on.
Um, we, we really don't have, uh, the type of community that we had at that time to, to kind of
think about these ideas, one of the things that was a very popular idea, and I think it
was taken largely from indigenous cultures like Mesoamerican culture was the, a connection
between events related to the sun and human consciousness.
So the way that, and I'm speaking broadly because I haven't prepared like a, a list, uh, you know,
specific sources of information related to various indigenous groups and how they look at the
sun and events related to the sun.
But the, the basic idea was the sun would respond like solar events would, uh, would happen
as a response to events amongst human beings.
And I don't think it's, it's not like one way causation.
It's more like a feedback loop between human consciousness and solar events.
And as we see like the, the warning signs that Ed and, and TRV, um, remote viewers have spoken
about in the past, it seems to me like we're looking at, um, a change in, um, human consciousness,
like a series of events that would be indicative of a change in human consciousness or the way
people lived.
Um, and when you talk about like this event occurring sort of at the climax, right?
As war is really about to get, you know, extreme, it, it seems to me that one could make an argument
that it's a real, a response, right?
That like the event comes at a certain, certainly if you are a believer in the Bible and biblical
prophecies, that's also something that biblical prophecies talk about, right?
Like the solar event occurring at a spur at a certain moment.
I think that it's, um, it's possibly, uh, uh, an event that's, that stops something worse
from happening.
I don't know if any of that has ever shown up in Killshot material.
I think I had a better idea of this in the nineties.
It's been a long time and my memory isn't what it used to be.
Yeah.
Um, so there, there, I am familiar, uh, again, in this case, I wasn't directly involved, but
I am familiar with, uh, some TRV work, uh, that more or less describes, um, again, I hesitate
to use a word like a causal effect or anything like that, but that yes, um, at some level,
uh, the dynamic at play here, it involves collective unconscious or, or cosmic type intelligence,
uh, interactions.
Um, if I remember correct, the term they used was, it seemed, it was sort of like a call
and response between the earth and, uh, the sun and the earth and its inhabitants rather
and, and the sun.
And yeah, I'm not sure directly comes from the RV work, but, uh, you could really safely
infer that such a disruptive event, uh, could actually prevent, uh, ultimately, uh, worse
things from happening.
Um, like for instance, if, and this is like completely speculative science fiction level
stuff, but like, if we imagine a storyline where say tech bros were about to turn human
beings into the Borg, right.
And so you were almost at that point where technology was about to erase human individuality, right.
And that itself would also have a dramatic effect on the earth and all life because of the,
the, the interaction with human beings in life and the importance that human empathy plays
in our interaction with nature and how we moderate the, the, um, the cost that we impose on nature,
even though what we, we put a terrible, like, uh, we, we, you know, we have a strong effect
on the natural world, right.
But it might be a, a greater effect if we lacked all human empathy, for instance, right.
So hypothetically, if, if you were sort of thinking about this in a, in a science fiction
sense, that might be one way of, of looking at it.
Like potentially we were in a situation where like, we almost made a transition to like non-carbon
based, something like that.
When they say non-carbon based life, which I think is an oxymoron, but when you have individuals
pursuing that path, one might look at this solar event as something that stops that from happening
potentially.
Uh, yeah, that's more or less exactly where I was going with that.
Yep.
Well, thank you.
I, and I, I look forward to, I, hopefully we can do this again next week.
And, uh, I think Wednesday is the night we're going to try, but it really depends on, on Matt's
schedule because he's a, he's a high powered professional.
And as you know, I'm, I'm not at this time.
Um, but I would look, I really look forward to talking about intuitive underground and how
it connects to all this and the intuitive underground session material and how, when you and I started
to work together, um, you know, maybe do another one on Astro RV at some point too.
Um, but I want to give Matt the chance to ask any, any follow-up questions.
We have about five, five-ish, 10 minutes at the most, um, before we would get to the point
where we have to start editing down because they really say you try to keep it under an
hour and a half.
People look for podcasts that are like an hour to an hour and a half in life.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um, I don't really have any direct questions regarding kill shot.
Um, I'm familiar enough with, with solar flares and how they might impact, uh, the, the grid
just because it's sort of related to my job.
It's, it's like very, so I work in with computers, software engineer, and it's very common when
we don't know why something didn't work or when something was broken to blame, you know,
solar flare.
So, um, I have, you know, that as reference.
Um, but yeah, for this particular, uh, topic, I don't really have any direct follow-up.
So I'd be ready to, to wrap things up.
And I want to thank Morgan for his time and, um, thanks for giving me the opportunity to
ask question, but, but I guess for right this moment, I don't have one.
All right.
Well, you know, I think that as the podcast, podcast goes on, like one of the, one of the
themes, you know, one of the ways of looking at things, it's really about taking information
and looking at it from different perspectives.
Right.
And so one of the perspectives is instead of, um, sort of a random linear series of events
propelled by previous events, instead of looking at it, like from the big bang model, right.
And then applying that to that metaphor to kind of understanding everything where someone
does something in 1940, and then it leads to something happening in 1960.
And, right.
So instead of looking at it from that perspective, one of the perspectives that I like to look
at things from is the, um, the present, you know, the past being drawn to the present,
right.
Like events happening specifically to set up for future events.
So for instance, um, using human psychic, you know, faculties and whether you are a strong
proponent of psychic ability or not, um, human beings and life in general, um, really exists,
um, as a way of anticipating environmental changes.
Like that's what life does.
Life, life behaves in a way that anticipates environmental changes.
And, and that's how life continues.
Right.
So, um, animals and plants, and we change as we approach the winter because the winter
is a, is a anticipatable, um, period of scarcity.
So in, in a similar way, there are periodic historical anticipatable periods of scarcity and
changes both in the environment and the natural world and in human beings.
And so one of the ways we look at things is, is how we are created or adapted.
Or evolved is designed to anticipate these events and prepare for them.
So when we look back at history, instead of seeing it just from the perspective of linear
step-by-step getting us to where we are now, we can look at it as like current events radiating
back into the past and in a wave pattern, really.
Um, and that's something we'll talk about in another, uh, or, or future, um, spaces.
So what I'm saying is that TRV, right?
Um, the importance of the quote, kill shot material and the session work around it is that it's
the most well-known and probably most, um, well-researched from the RV perspective, uh, session target
or, you know, that, um, in the history of remote viewing and definitely in the history of, of
technical remote viewing.
So, you know, remote viewing emerges onto the scene in the seventies, although they were
clairvoyant, claircognizant communities previous to that, but in its current form emerges onto
the scene and then comes and emerges into the public in the nineties.
And we can look at it as being sort of a random coincidence, or we can say like, what if there
was a reason?
Right?
Like what if there's an event and human beings are preparing for that event?
We're anticipating changes, environmental changes, global warming changes, resource scarcity changes.
You can, you can align that particular challenge with whatever your personal beliefs are.
But when we're looking at it is to look back as, as if these things are happening specifically
to prepare us for those challenges.
And so the existence of remote viewing in its current form may relate directly to doing
that.
And in which case the, the, the quote, kill shot material, um, from TRV is extremely important.
It's an extremely important transmission from the collective unconscious.
And I hope to talk about that more in the future, but next time with Morgan, I'm hoping
to focus on the intuitive underground material, which is in some senses related, but, um, is
much, uh, we are, you know, we're going to do, it's going to be more than one future podcast
on this because there's a lot there.
And, uh, I thank you all for, uh, listening to people who've turned tuned in live and people
who are going to be listening in the future, uh, the podcast.
Thank you very much for listening.
And, you know, we're getting better every time.
And this is important information and we are happy for the opportunity to bring it to you.
So that, that's what I have.
Um, any other closing remarks, comments, questions, concerns?
All right.
Well, it looks like everyone's good that Matt, thank you very much, um, for moderating and
running the podcast.
As always, you do a great job.
Um, the people who listened to the first two, uh, everyone who contacted me and commented on
it said, Hey, your brother's doing a great job.
Your brother's doing a great job.
I won't say what else they might've said because it was all good news about you.
Um, and I can tell Morgan agrees and Morgan, you know, people always love when you, when
you come into these spaces and, uh, you are an essential part of this.
And I think that one of the, one of the ways that I got off track was by trying to begin
the puzzle without you there.
And I don't know if that's possible because even though there were these events prior to
us, uh, beginning to work together, I think that those particular events may have been
that, that type of foreshadowing that I'm talking about.
Um, and that a certain, to a certain extent, the story really begins at that, at that point.
So, all right, guys, thank you, everyone.
Uh, everyone have a good night.
Um, it's going to be sort of a sudden end and, um, we'll talk to you later next week, next
Wednesday.
Go ahead, Morgan.
Oh, no, I just want to say, well, uh, uh, thanks for the invite.
Uh, JT pleasure as always.
And, uh, nice to meet you, Matt.
We'll, uh, we'll talk again.
Uh, I'm sure.
And, uh, and yes, I did.
I specifically told JT to tell your brother he's doing a good job.
All right, guys, I'm going to be back tomorrow doing a space that, that isn't related directly
to this podcast.
If anyone wants to tune in, because that's more conversational.
And so people can come up in comments, questions, concerns, uh, that they gained from this space
and we can talk about it, um, in that format.
Um, yeah, that's what I got.
All right, Matt, you want to close it out?
Yeah, uh, nothing else to say, but, uh, thank you and have a good night.